take a look at this work of art what is
it that you see at first glance it looks
to be a grandfather clock with a sheet
thrown over it and a rope tied around
the center but a first look always
warrants a second look again what do you
see now if you look more closely you'll
realize that this entire work of art is
made from one piece of sculpture there
is no clock
there is no rope and there is no sheet
it is one piece of bleached Honduras
mahogany now let me be clear this
exercise was not about looking at
sculpture it's about looking and
understanding that looking closely can
save a life change your company and even
help you understand why your children
behave the way that they do it's a skill
that I call visual intelligence and I
use works of art to teach everybody from
everyday people to those for whom
looking is the job like Navy SEALs and
homicide detectives and trauma nurses
the fact is that no matter how skilled
you might be at looking you still have
so much to learn about seeing because we
all think we did it in a first glance
and a sudden flash but the real skill is
in understanding how to look slowly and
how to look more carefully the talent is
in remembering in the crush of the daily
urgencies that demand our attention to
step back and look through those lenses
to help us see what we've been missing
all along so how can looking at painting
and sculpture help because art is a
powerful tool it's a powerful tool that
engages both sight and insight and
reframes our understanding of where we
are and what we see here's an example
of a work of art that reminded me that
visual intelligence it's an ongoing
learning process and one that really is
never mastered I came across this quiet
seemingly abstract painting
and I had to step up to it twice even
three times to understand why it
resonated so deeply now I've seen the
Washington Monument in person thousands
of times well aware of the change in the
color of marble a third of the way up
but I had never really looked at it out
of context or truly as a work of art and
here Georgia O'Keeffe's painting of this
architectural icon made me realize that
if we put our mind to it it's possible
to see everyday things in a wholly new
and eye-opening perspective now there
are sub skeptics that believe that art
just belongs in an art museum they
believe that it has no practical use
beyond its aesthetic value I knew who
they are in every audience I teach their
arms are crossed their legs are crossed
their body language is saying what am I
going to learn from this lady who talks
fast about painting and sculpture so how
do I make it relevant for them I asked
them to look at this work of art like
this portrait by kuma Yamashita and I
asked them to step in close and even
closer still and while they're looking
at the work of art they need to be
asking questions about what they see and
if they ask the right questions like
what is this work of art is it a
painting is it a sculpture what is it
made of they will find out that this
entire work of art is made of a wooden
board 10,000 nails and one unbroken
piece of sewing thread now that might be
interesting to some of you but what does
it have to do with the work that these
people do and the answer is everything
because we all interact with people
multiple times on a daily basis and we
need to get better and asking questions
about what it is that we see learning to
frame the question in such a way to
elicit the information that we need to
do our jobs is a critical life skill
like the radiologists who told me that
looking at the negative spaces in a
painting helped her discern more
discreet abnormalities in an MRI or the
police officer who said that
understanding the emotional dynamic
between people in a painting helped him
to read body language at a domestic
violence crime scene and it enabled him
to think twice before drawing and firing
his weapon and even parents can look to
see the absences of color in paintings
to understand that what their children
say to them is as important as what they
don't say so how do i how do i train to
be more visually intelligent it comes
down to four A's every new situation
every new problem we practice four A's
first we assess our situation we ask
what do we have in front of us then we
analyze it we say what's important what
do I need what don't I need then we
articulate it in a conversation in a
memo in a text an email and then we act
we make a decision we all do this
multiple times a day but we don't
realize what a role seeing and looking
plays in all of those actions and how
visual intelligence can really improve
everything so recently I had a group of
counterterrorism officials at a museum
in front of this painting El Greco's
painting the purification of the temple
in which Christ in the center in a
sweeping and violent gesture is
expelling the sinners from the temple of
Prayer the group of counterterrorism
officials had five minutes with that
painting and in that short amount of
time they had to assess the situation
analyze the details articulate what if
anything they were do if they were in
that painting as you can imagine
observations and insights differed who
would they talk to who would be the best
witness who was a good potential witness
who was lurking who had the most
information but my favorite comment came
from a seasoned cop who looked at the
central figure and said you see that guy
in the pink referring to Christ he said
I'd call her him he's causing all the
trouble
so looking at art gives us a perfect
vehicle to rethink how we solve problems
without the aid of technology looking at
the work of Felix gonzalez-torres you
see two clocks in perfect synchronicity
the hour minute and second hand
perfectly aligned they are installed
side by side and they're touching and
they are entitled untitled perfect
lovers but closer analysis makes you
realize that these are two
battery-operated clocks which in turn
makes you understand hey wait a minute
one of those batteries is going to stop
before the other one of those clocks is
going to slow down and die before the
other and it's going to alter the
symmetry of the artwork just
articulating that thought process
includes the necessity of a contingency
plan you need to have contingencies for
the unforeseen the unexpected and the
unknown whenever and however they may
happen now using art to increase our
visual intelligence involves planning
for contingencies understanding the big
picture and the small details and
noticing what's not there so in this
painting by Magritte noticing that there
are no tracks under the Train there is
no fire in the fireplace and there are
no candles in the candlesticks actually
more accurately describes the paging
than if you were to say well there's a
train coming out of a fireplace and
there are candlesticks on the mantel it
may sound counterintuitive to say what
isn't there but it's really a very
valuable tool when a detective who had
learned about visual intelligence in
North Carolina was called to the crime
scene it was a boating fatality and the
eyewitness told this detective that the
boat had flipped over and the occupant
had drowned of underneath now
instinctively crime-scene investigators
look for what is apparent but this
detective did something different he
looked for what wasn't there which is
harder to do and he raised the question
if the boat had really flipped over as
the eyewitness said that it did how come
the papers that were kept at one end of
the boat were completely dry based on
that one small but critical observation
the investigation shifted from
accidental death the homicide now
equally important to saying what isn't
there is the ability to find visual
connections where they may not be
apparent like Maria Watson's totem pole
of blankets it illustrates that finding
hidden connections in everyday objects
can resonate so deeply the artist
collected blankets from all different
people in her community and she had the
owners of the blankets right on a tag
the significance of the blanket to the
family some of the blankets had been
used for baby blankets some of them had
been used as picnic blankets some of
them had been used for the dog
we all have blankets in our homes and
understand the significance that they
play but similarly I instruct new
doctors when they walk into a patient's
room before they pick up that medical
chart just look around the room are
there balloons or cards or that special
blanket on the bed that tells the doctor
there's a connection to the outside
world if that patient has someone in the
outside world
to assist them and help them the doctor
can implement the best care with that
connection in mind in medicine people
are connected as humans before they're
identified as doctor and patient but
this method of enhancing perception it
need not be disruptive and it doesn't
necessitate an overhaul in looking like
Jorge Mendes Blake's sculpture of
building a brick wall above Kafka's book
El Castillo shows that more astute
observation can be subtle and yet
invaluable you can discern the book and
you can see how it disrupted the
symmetry of the bricks directly above it
but by the time you get to the end of
the sculpture you can no longer see the
book but looking at the work of art in
its entirety you see that the impact of
the works disruption on the bricks is
nuanced and unmistakable one thought one
idea one innovation can
altering approach change a process and
even save lives I've been teaching
visual intelligence for over 15 years
and to my great amazement and
astonishment to my never-ending
astonishment and amazement I have seen
that looking at art with a critical eye
can help to anchor us in our world of
uncharted waters whether you are a
paramilitary trooper a caregiver a
doctor or a mother because let's face it
things go wrong things go wrong and
don't misunderstand me I eat that
doughnut in a minute but we need to
understand the consequences of what it
is that we observe and we need to
convert observable details into
actionable knowledge like Jennifer Odum
sculpture of tables standing Sentinel on
the banks of the Mississippi River in
New Orleans guarding against the threat
of post Katrina floodwaters and rising
up against adversity we too have the
ability to act affirmatively
and affect positive change I have been
mining the world of art to help people
across the professional spectrum to see
the extraordinary in the everyday to
articulate what is absent and to be able
to inspire creativity and innovation no
matter how small and most importantly to
forge human connections where they may
not be apparent empowering us all to see
our work and the world writ large with a
new set of eyes thank you
[Applause]
[Music]